you're curious to know where everybody's
joining us from so if you want to put in
the chat
the city and Country
that would be great
foreign
the chat that you can put questions into
the Q a box I'll try to get to those at
the end of the session
hello
and welcome we're going to start in
about 30 seconds
all right
so let's get going
today's session we're going to be
bringing you
the recorded uh session with the
professor Ashraf from IU Germany
uh he presented about the program in
March so
I want to um present that and then I'll
take some of your questions but we've
included in this recording questions
that were answered
by the professor and uh shridi of the
IU Germany program
during that previous session so
I want to make sure that you get a
chance
to hear those
and let's begin
welcome to
this webinar on the partnership between
IU International University of Germany
and simply learn
and the MBA program I'm here with
Professor Muhammad ashfaq and he will
describe to you how this program works
we'll ask you a few questions along the
way
so Professor please go right ahead
first of all thank you so much to Simply
learn as well as to uh for organizing
this amazing webinar uh before I move
forward towards the webinar I would like
to briefly introduce myself my name is
Muhammad I'm a professor of business
administration
um and also the program director
apart from that as I also came to
Germany as a student I was born in
Pakistan I had my basic education there
and then I moved to Germany to study my
MBM and so this is where you know the
journey started and
um I would like to just let you know
that and I have of course I will talk
more um in the coming slides that you
know the MBA program in Germany uh
provides an amazing opportunity to all
of you because uh you know there's a
huge demand for the labor force which we
will talk you know in the coming slides
so first of all let me briefly introduce
um uh are you International University
of applied sciences so this is one of
our amazing campus
um in badhonif which is close to Bone
um please remember that bone was the
former capital of uh West uh Germany and
here
um as you can see
uh our university has more than uh you
know two decades um Cutting Edge
experience in
um in quality teaching uh research you
know and Innovative uh methods of
teaching are you International
University was founded in a 1998 and we
are the largest state accredited uh
University of applied sciences in
Germany and we have more than 100 000
students
it is my pleasure to let you know that
more than 97 uh is our recommendation
rate so those students who graduate from
our University they find job uh you know
as soon as possible and um so that is
why
um you know our recommendation rate is
very high
why are you um if the best in this space
because we have developed as I mentioned
earlier uh we have The Cutting Edge
experience of developing more than
um two decades of experience and we have
more than 150 000 learning hours
um in our library and we are currently
offering more than 200 different study
programs that consist of bachelor's
master and MBA programs we have three
study models um and four in text on
campus that you can take and we have two
International campuses one is bad horrif
which you can see this picture and the
other one is in um you know in Berlin so
here
um you know how are you if
um you know better or how are you stands
out compared to our competitors because
um we are the standard uh Setters uh in
high quality Education First of all the
benefit of studying at IU is we offer
great deal of flexibility
um because you can study in three
different
um you know Innovative you can use any
of the three Innovative models and
um if you are going to study online then
of course uh there's no fixed uh start
study date and exam period
um and we offer flexibility in terms of
studying full-time part-time
um as well as you know converting your
study from online to on campus so this
is first of all the flexibility and
remember that during covid-19 pandemic
uh one of the interesting things that we
human beings have learned is the
benefits of flexibility the second
benefit that we have is our digital
learning
um as I mentioned earlier that we have
Innovative tools of delivering education
the quality content we have our
dedicated IU love app which is powered
by artificial intelligence which
contains large course portfolios and as
a student you can access a variety of
tools and uh in order to engage with
your course area the third advantage and
third uh point that makes us different
is our career Focus as I mentioned
earlier that 97 is our recommendation
rate and 94 of our graduates find jobs
within six months of their graduation
we provide also in our online platform
um upskilling and reskilling courses so
that those areas which are in demand for
example uh you know Masters in Business
Administration in artificial
intelligence in data analysis in data
analytics uh in healthcare
um so we provide those uh kind of
courses
um because we understand the job market
and what are the requirements of the
market so that we can prepare our
graduates keeping in mind that the
fourth point that we have is
accessibility and affordability
so uh which you can of course uh about
affordability uh by the end of um you
know this presentation you will hear
more uh but as well as the accessibility
is concerned
um you can learn your material 24x7
there are no barriers there are you know
you have everything on your fingertips
and you have also access to your
teachers uh you can write them a message
or you can you know you can engage for a
course so that you know any issues that
you are facing as a student that can be
clarified and the final point that I
would like to talk about is the
recognition IU has been recognized
um based on our quality uh based on our
teaching uh innovations that we have by
various uh you know certifications and
accreditations that we have received we
are also a member of uh aafcb and we
have received one of uh the Europe's uh
best accreditations
um and we have been constantly ranked on
the top positions uh in ranking such as
c-h-e uh bifq Awards and so on so these
are some of the reasons um that makes us
uh one of the best uh institution uh in
terms of providing quality education
so as you can also see here in this um
the multiple different awards that you
have received
um you know convectively and
um recently we have also signed a double
degree
um our agreement with um one of the UK
universities so London South Bank
University so that if you are studying
at IU in selected study programs you can
also receive a double degree from the
United Kingdom without paying any
additional cost or any other additional
fee
um and
um we are the leader of innovation in
education and technology management and
you know we have been constantly uh
ranked um the top uh education provided
by our alumni
so here if we look at
um you know any organization
um and especially for an academic
organization the academy the corporate
Partners play an important role because
we have our career service department
that is uh very proactive and strong
that enable our students to prepare them
for the future in terms of looking at
the cover letter looking at the CV other
documentations and preparing them for
the interviews we have developed a
strategic Partnerships with corporate
um players like Microsoft Accenture BMW
group you know leaked in learning to a
group Volkswagen Henkel so this vast you
know uh network of our
more than 10 000 our you know Partners
enable our students to go for
internships to go for you know work
student positions as well as for job
employment after they graduate so that
is one of our key strength areas
now after providing you the brief
overview about the history of IU and why
IU is uh the leader in quality education
in online now I would like to provide
you some information about Career
Services which I have are briefly
already explained but now here
um the career service department ensures
that our students are well equipped they
have all the necessary tools and
techniques
um that enable them to find a suitable
position for their career so how the
career service department enables first
of all
um they offer individualized Consulting
and support for example preparation of
an application documents please remember
that in various countries there are
different you know ways to apply and
documentations that are needed how you
prepared your CV so this individualized
Consulting and support enable students
um to cater uh you know their future
needs in a careful manner so that they
do not waste their time uh in finding an
internship or a job they are well ready
what kind of documentation they need uh
in order to apply for that
the second is workshops on key topics
for example we offer workshops on
business cultures or um you know
Intercultural management
um also about the contract negotiations
our salary negotiations so these kind of
additional workshops enable our students
to be
um you know to be well aware of the
current market trends and uh they can
present themselves in a better way then
exposure to the companies
um we invite the carrier service
department they invite industry speakers
and organize corporate events so that
you know the guest speakers can share uh
lies about the future HR Trends or what
employees are expecting from the
employees and finally the career service
department also offers free of course
free of charge German language
um you know so that students can also
learn a new language please understand
that learning a German language is
always a great benefit because it opens
the labor market for you not only in
Germany but you know in
um in Switzerland as well as Austria and
some parts of
um the Belgium so this is uh how the
career service department offers its
services to enable our students so that
they are well prepared and as far as the
study and work in Germany is concerned
Germany is ranked as the top destination
in Europe for higher education uh
because
um in journal the quality of Education
in Europe is uh very high and at IU we
focus
um that our students get the best
um you know learning
learning content as well as experience
so that they can they can lead
um you know from the front
um so Germany has been um conductively
uh ranked on the top position another
important benefit as a student that you
can get while studying at IU and
studying in Germany is if you are coming
on campus you can receive after you are
finishing your degree 18 month stay back
option this will know allow you to find
a job and you know as I mentioned
earlier mostly our students receive
their job offers uh pretty soon but this
is a great benefit that it'll enable you
to find a job in a stress-free
environment
apart from that as a student you have
the entitlement of working as uh you
know 120 full days in a year of course
during your studies you can also work as
a part-time
um so so that you can also Finance your
studies so this
um and finally another point is more
than
um you know uh 500
um thousand vacant positions are
available in Europe
um and especially in Germany there is a
huge demand of uh the educated and uh
you know Innovative Workforce because
the already Workforce like people are
you know getting retired so therefore
there are you know thousands of
um vacant positions to be filled to be
uh Filled from
um and this is an excellent way for you
as a student that you can come to
Germany and um you can you know play
your but um
and as far as the labor market of
Germany is concerned we have roughly by
the end of 2021 45 billion people in
Germany are working and
um and as you can see from here we have
um the lowest unemployment rate in
Europe uh in Germany so you know which
is a very negligible and as I mentioned
this makes a Germany one of the best
places to work because there are
thousands of
um successful Innovative German
companies that are operating in various
parts of the world in India as well and
similarly Indian companies are also
operating in Germany so this gives us uh
you know a perfect sport to work and to
play your role uh in Bridging the
different cultures and uh playing
um you know in the society playing your
role in the society
now after talking about the career
services uh the second point I would
like to talk about our online studies
um I have already worked as a professor
of business
um so I have been teaching at NBA
courses at our campus in born in barbone
but recently I have moved towards our
distance learning unit
therefore it gives me as a professor
unique benefits uh you know to work
online uh in a in a very convenient and
flexible way so here
um what you can study in our online so
as our IU MBA program is best recognized
um uh for an online study there are two
options that you can have you can have
MBA for 60 uh ectf which is the European
credit transport system or you can
enroll in the MBA program that we have
90 credit points and as you can see here
we have uh broad range of
specializations that we have prepared by
keeping in mind the demand for the
future
um what kind of
specializations are needed uh by the
employers for example big data
management Engineering Management
Financial Accounting I.T management
um for international companies it is
particularly important to have special
aggression in International Management
and emerging tools and techniques like
artificial intelligence Innovation and
Entrepreneurship
um Supply Chain management and
Salesforce so these are some of the
specializations that we are offering you
can start your study
um MBA at any time and you can join our
campus uh four times a year so
traditionally there is one or two times
offering but our Innovative
um uh you know study model enable us to
enroll our students on campuses up to
four times a year and you can also be
flexible if you are working uh in your
home country you can take part in as a
part-time student other way around you
can also you know uh study full-time or
maybe you can have extended study model
so
um the another amazing benefit of online
our MBA program is that you can take
part in all examinations online so
there's no paperwork enrolled there's no
you know specific dates for as long as
you finish a course you are
independently able to go for an online
examination and earlier I also mentioned
that if you are studying uh with us
um at IU the MBA program you can also go
for the uh double degree with lfbu with
that is
University so the aim the purpose of our
MBA program is to broaden your horizons
to uh so that our students also gain and
attain specialist knowledge in a
specific field so that they can build
their expertise
so
here I would like to also talk about IU
artificial intelligence program remember
that according to a recent research it
is expected that
um by the end of 2030 artificial
intelligence is going to contribute up
to 4 trillion US dollars to the global
economy so there are huge opportunities
for artificial intelligence
um so you can take part in our MSC
artificial intelligence that is 120
Credit Point um and you can specialize
in one of the areas such as
um you know you can go deep uh learn
about how humans and machine interrupt
you know interaction Works
um how language
um and image processing work what is the
role of Industry 4.0 and Internet of
Things robotics
um how the autonomous you know vehicles
and are driving
um currently the future trends of food
future Mobility project management with
I AI projects so these are the amazing
courses that we have included in our MSC
artificial intelligence that enables you
to be the leader to be well prepared uh
for the changing roles and you know the
new skills that are needed by the
industry similarly along with MBA
program uh here you have also the option
to engage in
um a double degree program a double
degree from lsbu
now we have also developed an amazing uh
program that is of MSC Engineering
Management so those students who have a
background uh in engineering and you
would like to further
um enhance your skills so this is a
perfect
um uh place for you if you would like to
go for an international consultancy or
if you would like to move up in the
managerial positions because this MSC
management 60 Credit Point course
enables you to get key skills and
experience and knowledge in the area
such as Internet of Things
manufacturing methods current issues in
Engineering Management and product
development so this is uh of course you
can go for full-time or part-time as
well
now
um that I I provided you a brief
overview about our various
um study um our MBA program
um Engineering Management as well as MSC
artificial intelligence
um once you enroll at IU you will gain
an exclusive access to our online
learning portal which is known as my
campus which is a dedicated portal where
you have each and everything
um as well as you will get an excess of
IU learn app which is powered by the
artificial intelligence so that you can
um you can get each and everything on
your finger tips
so
now uh I would like to talk about
briefly uh entry
um criteria for the MBA program so uh as
I mentioned earlier so we have two types
of mbas one is the MBA one year and this
the other option is MBA one and a half
years uh one year MBA program is 60 uh
credit points
on the other hand 90 credit points MBA
is one and a half year so first of all
for
MBA program what a minimum requirements
are demanded at your end you should have
a bachelor degree
or a provisional certificate or a
graduation certificate
you should have also a Consolidated
transcript of your records so overall we
expect minimum 50 of uh cgp at GPM and a
copy of your international passport
a copy of your resume and then English
test
um results so you can go for IELTS a
minimum level six are you know TOEFL
with uh 80 points minimum
plus you need a work experience
certificate of one year so a proven work
experience
um
in the form of a written certificate
that you have received your one year
work experience after your graduation
please remember that this work
experience is only counted if this is
after your graduation
and please note that
offered position letter or acceptance
letter or resignation letter or salary
slips or work contract they are not
considered in Germany as an experienced
letter so I will show you also the
template how an experienced letter look
like so in order to start your 60
ectf that means one year MBA program you
need to have
achieved already
210 ects credits for example you should
have already studied Bachelor's in
technology or you know Bachelor's in
engineering so that means four-year
mandatory study duration
however for your 90 ectf
MBA program you need to have a 180 180
ectf credits for example you should have
completed Bachelor's in Commerce
Bachelor's of business administrations
uh bachelors in mass communication so
which means a three-year mandatory study
duration
please also note that in order to
receive a double degree from lfdu we
require a two years of work experience
um because this is a requirement from
the lsbu
um at IU our requirement is one year but
in case you would like to go for a
double degree then you should have
two-year work experience
and let me show how a sample experience
letter look like so as you can see here
this sample such kit shows what was the
position
uh what are the key job description so
that means at least three clear
descriptions of the job that you're
supposed to are you you are doing then
working hours whether it is full time or
it is part-time so it should be written
as uh you know
um in terms of time management and then
starting date and ending date and clear
name of your employer employers
signature and contact information so
this is
um a
sample experience letter that we
acknowledge so therefore please keep in
mind uh you know before submitting your
work experience so your work experience
should include all these important
points to be considered as a valid work
experience
know how the application process works
so you know you will start your
application at simply learn so you will
submit your applications for example
initial contact with simply learn then
the second step is submit your documents
to Simply learn in the third step you
will receive your study contract
uh once uh V and simply learn go through
your documents and we identify that
everything is okay and we satisfied uh
with the documentation process then you
will receive your study contract the
fourth step would be sign your study
contract in the fifth step receive your
IU login credentials for your my campus
for IU learn app and the final step is
onboarding for my campus platform which
simply learn so simply learn will help
you explain you how you can use uh best
the my campus portal in order to maximum
benefit from this portal
now I would like to finally uh also talk
about on campus studies as I have
already mentioned we have two
International campsites by the way we
have more than 40 campsies in Germany
but on those capsules we offer dual uh
studies in German uh that is do all
studio in English dual studies means
those employees who are working in the
companies they they work three days and
Company they come two days um at our
University to study and so we have so
mostly in dual campus which we have 40
campuses in Germany the medium of
instruction is German language however
we have two International campsites
earlier mentioned Berlin which is a
metropolitan capital city which is one
of the largest uh cities in Europe and
of course in Germany because it's a
capital it offers great opportunities
for social utilization you know bars
clubs restaurants and it is also
international business Hub so there are
many startup and tech companies
operating from Berlin
and then we have the part of Campus so
this is the campus where I am based and
this is one of the amazing uh you know
Campus located
um in the mountains and you have
um also sports clubs different societies
um cologne and Bone are nearby cities so
you will have if you are coming on bad
honif so you will have uh you know the
transportation ticket that is included
in your study so you can access these uh
metropolitan cities and enjoy
um in your free time and this region of
bad honeft offers
um you know many International companies
head offices for example Metro
um for example DHL for example Deutsche
telephone so there are many other
International companies that are working
in this region which offer great uh
employment opportunities
now uh how learning works on campus um
you know as I mentioned
um sometimes we need human interaction
with socialization and
Campus Life offers
um this kind of benefits that you can
meet a different uh people coming from
different nationalities different
backgrounds different cultures so that
you can enhance your Intercultural
skills as well
um so at campus our aim is to provide
you know content
um to a small group of numbers so our
classes are maximum number of students
we allow in our classrooms are 25 the
purpose of having a smaller class
participation so that we can offer
maximum focus and attention to our
students
um and of course we also offer free
language courses uh so that we can
prepare you know our students so that
they can additionally learn and uh one
more language because language is also a
great benefit for your career for rest
of your life
so um our holistically our focus is to
provide in-depth um you know classes
student-centric case study based um
which is based on the practice
um oriented learning
um uh and we also
um you know in white industry guest
lectures
um to our campaign so that they can also
share their experience uh with our
students
so earlier I mentioned that
um with our new uh Innovative model we
allow our students that they can
um you know they can join our campus
um during a year up to four times so
that means there are four intakes that
we offer and as you can see
um uh our blog one star for example on
October then the next block starts in
January then the third block starts in
April and the final book starts in you
know uh by the end of uh June so this uh
offers a great uh deal of flexibility
um we one block is consisting of nine
week blocks of teaching and in one block
you can take three modules at a time
um and then you will also receive uh you
know two weeks time period for your uh
preparation for your exam
um so this is an assessment uh you know
assessment preparation time period and
these uh intakes are happening at the
specified you know a month that I have
earlier mentioned and students also get
a four week study break in September so
that you can spend summer vacations or
maybe you can travel back to your home
countries so this is an amazing
flexibility that we offer in our these
uh four intake model um studying at IU
so I have briefly already explained
um the six steps that you can follow in
order to apply
um for our campus studies as well so
if the simply learned and earlier I
explained these um
okay now
um we have also as I mentioned earlier I
I would like to before I go forward uh Q
and A I would like to once again briefly
um highlight the importance of flexible
learning if some of you are working and
work maybe working full time and
currently you are unable to relocate due
to your work or due to your family
engagements to Germany so you can start
your MBA program
um you know at home online later on in
your second semester or in your third
semester you can come to Germany and you
can complete your rest of the studies
here and of course once you come to
Germany you will have the entitlement of
18 month stay
um here uh and job search Visa which is
a great benefit for our International
students and our next intakes
um are going to take place in October
April so
um once again I would like to greatly
thank you for your attention and thank
you for joining us as I given you my
example you can see that one student
from Pakistan came to Germany to do the
MBA program and then of course I was uh
after my MBA program I was working in
multinational companies like Henkel and
Pfizer manufacturing
um and then I did my PhD and later on
you know
um it was my passion to work in the
economic side so I became a professor so
uh I'm coming you know our
subcontinental culture is the same so
I'm I'm a perfect example in front of
you that there is there are huge
opportunities for you so here you need
to stay focused you need to you know
make a plan what you are going to do
when you are going to do and then stay
focused you know there are many
opportunities and
um I have no doubt that each and every
one of you are talented person done and
you will find your way and there are
great opportunities that are waiting for
you at IU as well as in Germany and in
Europe
thank you so much and please feel free
if you have any questions
and before we go on
I want to just say that we I see your
questions coming in and I'll take those
toward the end but I wanted to share
with you the Q a that the professor and
uh pretty uh sorry
Trudy from the uh
IU organization
took on this original session so that
maybe some of your concerns will be
answered there from them and I will take
your questions after that so here's what
they've had to say
there we go
um so we have a number of questions that
have come in from our q a channel here
and um
I think you covered this one from Niraj
who asks what the main specialization
tracks are for the MBA program you've
got a slide that discussed there were
how many uh 13 counted
yes there are several specializations
that we offer
um that include you know
um big data management engineering uh
management Finance and Accounting
artificial intelligence I.T Management
International marketing International
Management of human resource management
um uh entrepreneurship and Innovation
Healthcare Management Supply Chain
management Esports and Salesforce
okay
um amid asks if uh is the 60 credit
version
um essentially an Executive MBA
would you characterize it that way
well
um
we can say that that for women like that
MBA point of view so here uh our focus
is that someone had already a good solid
work experience and uh
um they can you know complete
um you know in one year program
um yeah his concern had to do with the
fact that he's got 10 years of
experience so
um he's looking forward that is that is
quite good
um
so uh Dr Pavan asks if you have joined
the online classes you are then able to
um
opt for the uh
on campus in your second semester and
later yes that is possible uh so then
you need to in advance tell us that okay
you are going to do first semester
online and then the second semester on
campus because we have limited number of
floors on campus so this is possible
and there is a additional fee for coming
onto campus but if you is the the
program possible to do completely online
yes that is completely possible you can
finish your complete program online as
well
um
who would you recommend
if they're considering between the 60
and the 90 unit programs
which one is suitable for which type of
learner
okay well um first of all this is an
interesting question and we need to look
at the individual requirements uh you
know uh in 90 uh credit program we have
you know further courses so if you would
like to go for more courses and you
would like to get some Diversified
number of courses then of course 90
Credit Point is uh the perfect option
but if you would like to go for you know
a selected courses and then your thesis
and you have time limitations and you
are a busy person you cannot or from
your family or from your work experience
point of work point of view you cannot
be away from your work than one credit
UH 60 Credit Point is also the suitable
option so it depends on individual
circumstances
to what I would like to add in one more
Point here from the from the eligibility
uh criteria point of view so uh students
who would be opting for 60 ects MBA they
need to have uh four years of
undergraduate studies uh so here in
India it would be mostly students with
engineering background Tech background
who actually have four years of
undergraduation uh with other students
they will have to take the you know 1.5
years of MBA with specializations so
basically students with four years of
undergraduation they get a choice either
to do a general MBA which is MBA 60 CTS
or MBA 90 CTS but students with three
years of undergraduation they
compulsively will have to choose an MBA
with specialization because we are not
able to bridge the gap of the ects that
they're missing okay
and that was one of the other questions
about the difference uh whether there is
a what are there specialization options
in the 60 unit program
UH 60 acts unfortunately doesn't have
any any specialization uh you know
courses as such uh also
um I would like to even touch upon one
more Point here pertaining to the German
language courses so uh on campus for all
the students we have everything that is
you know app based we even have speaks
for example you know English speaking uh
program for students who would be
joining us online if they have not taken
aisle to fill at the beginning because
for campus they will certainly require
this in the same manner we also have
German uh language course for these
students free of course which is again
to be consumed online but uh from April
onwards we would be launching a German
language program on campus it will be
there but there'll be certain charges
there'll be certain fee that would be
attached to it that you know that we
could announce it in the month of April
so this was one update that I wanted to
add also from an MBA perspective as you
know very recently uh
our eligibility criteria has changed and
uh very happy to announce that from two
years which was in the past you know
some 15 days back now it has become one
year of work experience that is going to
be required so please do make the most
of the opportunity that now you can
actually be able to be part of the MBA
program with one year of less work
experience
um regarding German language we also had
a couple of questions about how vital it
is to know the German language if your
plan is to work in Germany is that uh
extremely important well uh you know
um it is an interesting question if
someone has a language additional
language that always pay back you in
several ways so there are multinational
companies as I mentioned the Henkel
Pfizer Metro Group you know buyer Bosch
Apple uh you know Dell you don't need
um to have a German language so there's
no prerequisite but however a language
enable you to socialize with local
Germans your colleagues and to leave a
good impression and you know if you go
for the leadership positions and you
become a manager director and the CEO
and CFO for company then of course you
need to take everyone on the board and
language will you know support you in
that progression
thank you for that
um we had a question from someone who is
pursuing an online MBA the different
program is there any transferability
they switched to uh the IU simply
learned program
well in general there should be but it
we need to look at the particular case
our specific case so that you know the
CN can be made but in general if it is
possible to switch from one course to
another or from one specialization to
another
normally it should not be the problem
okay and
and we did have a question from
OMSI who asked if is possible to do in
the 90 unit program two semesters online
and one semester on campus
um unfortunately that is not a
possibility anymore uh students if they
are opting say for an hybrid model they
will compulsory they will have to do one
semester online and two semesters on
campus Because later you would also be
making application for post study visas
you would want to stay back to you know
get get the experience working in German
companies in doing internships or you
know to to gain that kind of an
experience so it is crucial that you're
there in that last year again a complete
uh absorb everything culturally as well
as you know all all the other
experiences in terms of taking the
courses internships uh and working so
with you know keeping all that in mind
it is not possible to do one semester on
campus and also please do keep in mind
that the last semester is mostly you
know it consists of thesis which in
which there is no teaching as such so we
don't want to give you an experience
wherein you come on campus and you would
just do thesis so keeping all these uh
points uh you know in mind it is for MBA
90 CTS it is always one plus two as a
part of hybrid model that we offer thank
you
um last question from our audience uh
someone with a design background is
looking to get a master's in design
I'm presuming that this would not be the
best program for someone pursuing that
that course is that true or or do you
have other offerings
uh so certainly so basically yes it is a
full-time course that you uh that we're
offering together with simply learn uh
uh I mean if you wish to do it online
that is certainly a possibility if you
are someone who would like to opt it in
a part-time uh part-time model also that
is also something that could be looked
in in case if you are someone that you
could not have uh you know who do not
have uh I mean good amount of time to
actually devote yourself to studies uh
so that is again fee and everything
changes the structure changes every uh
you know as as the time model changes
but we do some uh you know some limited
structured programs with them so uh I
mean you can you can see how it fits you
and you could take a call likewise okay
and I think that the question had to do
with the field of
design as a discipline but it
that's a
I think this is
an MBA
okay unfortunately we do not have this
specialization with you with us at the
moment okay
well um there is one last question from
Jody who asks is there a time limit for
finishing the program so if you are
reaching the end of the first year of
your studies with the 60 unit program
for example
um is there do you have to finish by
that 12-month period uh yes ideal in an
ideal scenario yes you should be
finishing your program uh you know in
the given time limit but if by any uh
you know by you know I mean you're not
able to complete it in any scenario
wherein you know you have other
commitments or
if you lag behind then certainly there
is a possibility that you can extend
your studies so for example if you're
not able to study a 60 CTS program in 12
months time you can extend it by another
six months by paying additional fee so
it won't so happen that uh you know uh
that that your uh that your account
would uh you know would be blocked or so
you'll just have to pay additional fee
and you can extend your study program so
this is something that you will have to
keep in mind because an access will be
given only for that specific study
period uh to you okay thank you very
much um
so
now what I'd like to do is take uh some
of the questions that have come in from
you and our live audience this evening
and we have one from Amit
you have a technical question about the
the program itself because you're
already enrolled in the NBA 60 ects
program
um so I would direct your question
to the
um
I would direct your question to your
program counselor or program uh success
manager
uh so that they can answer your question
about adding more subjects
um so that's a
specific question for because you're
already a student
um
does this program contain
graduate and postgraduate courses so
this is a essentially a postgraduate or
a master's degree accredited Master's of
business administration degree
and of course you heard the professor
talk about a couple of other masters
programs that are also available
um
through
simply learned an IU partnership
um
so yes this is a fully accredited uh
graduate degree
we did have a question from uh Siddharth
who asked about the e-sports
specialization and whether that was
Affiliated to uh EA's
the company and it's not it covers uh
the general field of Esports which is
become a
big worldwide business so that's why
it's covered in one of the
specializations is it mandatory to have
English language proficiency uh and I
guess I believe that is required
um but that will be part of the
assessment when you um
contact
us at simply learn and go through the
evaluation process
and
Priya had asked about the length of the
course and and as you know it's uh
it's either oh
60 CTS course which is
one full year or
90 ects which is 18 months
let's go into the actual q and a box
which is where I asked you to put the
questions so I will go right there
and how much funding do you need to
study on campus
so I will share with you the course fees
shortly but um there's a basic fee for
doing the program fully online and then
there's additional
optional fees if you want to do the
on-campus study
um
I have one question what if I don't have
formal experience I would have worked as
a part-time freelancer I do not know
what the
um
answer to that is but I would encourage
you to contact us by email to evaluate
that because they may be able to tell
you how to document your experience in
such a way that it meets The Experience
requirement
um
I heard a YouTuber saying education in
Germany is free
uh that would be true if you are a
German citizen
um it is not free to um
people who are international students
studying from other coming from other
countries
um
is MBA and digital marketing available I
believe that is one of the
specializations you can do in the 90
ects program
how exactly is the curriculum divided
between IU and LSB you would need to
contact
UM
us and our learning consultant can help
you with that
um but generally speaking it's uh
mainly through IU and then
semester of
courses through LSB
uh Priya if you what if I can't come to
the campus you can do the 60 ects
program fully online
um you would want to ask about the 90
CTS version
um
if you study one semester on campus how
many months will you get a post-study
Visa
um
I'd refer to our web page but I believe
it is a 12-month period
and
when is the next batch coming after
April 2023 so we have a cohort starting
26 April
next week
but the next one would be three months
after that in around June July
and
the 18-month course is not mentioned on
the simply learned website you would
want to contact us and um
get more details sent to you in
particular
the website gives an overview of the 60
ects program but of course the full 90
uh ects program is available and
so you want to ask that question through
our learning Consultants
and lalit uh
yes this course isn't an MBA as you
heard from the professor we do offer the
Masters in Engineering Management and we
do offer the uh Masters of Science and
AI programs from IE Germany so you could
for those of you who are interested in
those types of programs you can also
look at those but
so that covers
the questions